good evening everybody and welcome to
this overview and scrutiny committee
meeting on thursday the 14th of october
2021. good evening
my name is council vanessa bell and
thank you very much for turning up those
of you who have
my name is councillor vanessa berlin i'm
the chairman of this committee and
before we commence the business there
are a few housekeeping issues to run
through
um as you can tell we are having a
slightly different format this evening
and we're we're the guinea pig meeting
so we have officer support remotely
and uh
that means i get to present the report
all on my own later on so we're seeing
how this works as a meeting so please
bear with us if there are any
issues
thank you
so um yeah we are
working to the project there covered
protocols and we're streaming the
meeting live as well as recording so by
being present in the meeting you are
giving your consent to be recorded
members during each item please put your
hand up or just ask because i think
there are a few enough of us to manage
that
and i'll invite you to speak the
appropriate time
so please remember to turn your
microphone on when you're speaking and
off when you have finished speaking
and i also need to draw your attention
to the
uneven levels in the floor when you're
leaving the building just in case
and fire exit door
is behind us
okay item two may i have the apologies
for absence please tara
thank you chairman yes apologies have
been received from council passenger
councilman mcbeal and councillor helm
thank you chairman thank you tara
item three minutes
so it's recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 12th of august
found on pages 5 to 10
are approved as a true and accurate
record i so move do you have a section
of that motion
thank you we breathe out
super that's three by a cent thank you
a bit where i get my teeth in a twist
declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other pecuniary
interests or non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded also that they are
required to declare any interests if
they become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting any declarations
of interests
that's
nice thank you chair just to say that uh
i am acquainted um and a also a fellow
um parish councillor with uh item five
six i believe it is
okay thank you very much i believe
that's cancer swain's item
sorry uh seven seven oh okay okay lovely
thank you very much
so that does bring us to
oh i'm being advised that you didn't
need to declare as you're not a
committee member but thank you for
sharing i thought i would
so that brings us to public
participation um to receive the views of
um
well i forget the exact wording but you
are um
i've got it on my thing isn't it invited
in attendance member
who
is
has been given
permission by the chair to speak so i
shall stop waffling council morris and i
will invite you to speak
do i get my two minutes up
oh i don't have to do the two minutes
officers are you able to do the two
minutes for me
that's okay counselor i'm counselling i
want to stick to the rules you see
thank you very much okay when you're
ready
thank you very much chair um i noticed
that uh item 7 is
the
small
wrecked
seating area the promenade that
stinks of urine and is inaccessible to
people with disabilities
and i was just uh wondering that um if
this is a matter for overview and
scrutiny
why aren't we
scrutinizing and overviewing the
unlawful acts of this council and also
the tens or possibly hundreds of
thousands of pounds that this council
have given
to uh who knows
ex-staff members
that
have been paid off
i call them legal bribes non
disclosure agreements
and
we have no idea how much they've been
given why they've been given and on at
least two occasions that i know of they
possibly are to hide criminal activity
um i've no longer got any email so i
can't email anyone about this anymore um
so i just uh you know asked the
committee if they're prepared to take
oral representations about stuff that
i'd like to be brought here okay council
morris we do need to i'm not
interrupting you you finished yet uh
well i was just going to say that i was
trying to respond yes
i was just going to say that prince
andrew needs ex extradition as well
thank you thank you i think you forgot
to say that last night councilor maurice
so
um i think in the en i believe in the
interest of democracy there needs to be
a way for you as a member to present
items for
scrutiny so
we need to find a way for that to happen
now whether that is orally or whether
that is by
snail mail or how that is i don't as yet
know but i agree that there must be a
way for all members
to
request items as scrutinized by this
committee so councilman i will take your
request on board i will research the way
in which that can be done and
i will do what i can to facilitate that
in time for the next working group
meeting is that acceptable thank you
very much that is thank you super thank
you very much council morris so
moving on to item six
which is the report on the requested
scrutiny items which you'll find on
pages 11 to 14.
now bear with me
because um
i have to read this out myself so i have
to find my
chairman's chat is popping up on my
screen just where i need to
okay
so
the purpose of this report is to update
the committee on working group
discussions and recommendations on the
two scrutiny items which we have
and the recommendations are that the
committee receives and considers the
recommendation of the working group on
the requested scrutiny item
councillor wagon as set out in appendix
a for occlusion conclusion inclusion in
the scrutiny work plan
and little two that the committee
endorses the conclusions of the working
group in relation to the request by
councillor c swain that this item is not
added to the scrutiny work plan but
dealt with as set in paragraph 3.3 of
this report
of the key issues which we are looking
at
in accordance with the agreed initial
review process for scrutiny items
requested by members the committee's
working group met on the 20th of august
to consider two new requests
the first request by councillor lagan
regarding the decision-making processes
associated with the proposed conversion
of a seating shelter in prominent park
moulden was supported by the working
group for inclusion in the committee's
work plan and is detailed in appendix a
the questions to be addressed through
scrutiny have been drafted by officers
to reflect the reviews of the views of
the working group
in acknowledgment of the fact that it
was not being asserted that the
necessary delegated powers did not exist
or that officers had stepped beyond them
the working group concluded that in a
wider context there were concerns over
the actual exercise of these powers in
relation to certain operational matters
second request was by council chris
swain in relation to fred frad i haven't
got my teeth in tonight i do apologize
yes please
flood risk in haybridge he noted that
various agencies are involved with a
variety of different assets and felt
that the council needed to be assured
that each is maintaining its assets in a
proper management scheme and what the
latest assessment of the state of those
assets is
further he wished to ascertain whether
there are any disputed assets or assets
with uncertain ownership
this had not been raised with any other
committee or with officers and the
working group concluded that as
presented this was an essentially an
information gathering exercise designed
to provide a clearer understanding of
the respective responsibilities and also
a level of assurance that those
responsibilities are being met
so in other words it was really rather
than scrutiny item he was seeking
information so we will find a way to
provide that information to council
spain
the working group was advised that
officers had provided an explanatory
note of the council's responsibilities
alongside those of its partners the
various liaison and joint working
arrangements and an updated management
response to the issues raised in the
audit report on flood risk management
approved by the performance government
and audit committee in september 2020.
further officers were prepared to run a
q a information session for members to
promote greater understanding and
assurance
in the absence of the identification of
anything specific to be scrutinized this
approach was supported by the working
group for endorsement by the committee
the working group did however observe
that despite all the plans liaison and
joint working there was still a flooding
problem in haybridge and felt that the
council's understanding of the reason
for this needs to be better communicated
to the public
so in conclusion the information is set
out to update the committee on the
recent working group meeting and
recommend an item for scrutiny work plan
that has been identified as a result
and i don't think i need to go through
the um impact matrix so
members over to you and you were happy
to are happy to agree the reports
recommendations
council lagging do you wish to speak i
may invite you as it's your item
no i believe it is in my gift i possibly
should have taken you under item five
but uh
thank you very much so members can we
agree by ascent that uh
the recommendations are accepted
that's super thank you very very much
so then i believe
we are moving on to
sorry i should have asked you to second
that it felt a bit unnecessary with the
massive number of members we have here
at this meeting
i do not have any other items of urgent
business which brings us smartly to
closure of the meeting
at
1941. thank you very much
we are rather sorry to have brought you
out in the cold for uh
but thank you very much everyone
you